- Après des années à ne pas
se faire écouter, ça suffit.
La crise du logedididididididid.
- Des organismes communautaires
et des citoyens ont manifesté
du logement au Québec.
- Ces deux hommes vivent dans
le même immeuble résidentiel,
ils font face à une augmentation
de loyer importante.
0 0 0 $ par mois d'augmentation.
J'ai dû prendre un avocat qui
me coûte beaucoup d'argent.
autres, ils ont pas beaucoup
d'argent non plus, fait qu'ils
peuvent pas se défendre.
- Hausses de loyers, évictions
et pénurie de logements
abordables, les locataires sont
dénonce le Regroupement
des comités de logement.
MARJOLAINE DENEAULT, Regroup.
- La crise du logement touche
des villes comme Montréal
et Québec, mais touche aussi
des villes où il y a moins de
ressources, des plus petites
- Selon la SCHL, le taux
d'inoccu s s s sur le marché
locatif frôle les 0 % dans
certaines villes. Il est
de. . . . . . . . . . . . . . Àx
d'inoccupatione e e e 3 %.
Il est à 2,5 % à Québec.
La ministre de l'Habitation,
Andrée Laforest, reconnaît
en partie cette crise.
ANDRÉ H H H H H H H H H H H H Hn
- Il faut être très prudents,
ce n'est pas à la grandeur du
Québec, mais de toeeeeeeeeeeeeee
en mode solution et de rattraper
le retard du p, , , , , on
augmente l'offre. On est rendus
à 8000 logements livrés, on a00.
esesesesesesesesesesesesesesesee
par la pandémie et la hausse
ûûûûûts de construction.eseseses
logement, c'est un gel
des loye r r r r registre
public afin de réguler le prix
des logements.
Ici Marie-Isachchchchchon,
Radio-Canada, Montréa